- So you just became a
mom, congratulations.
- I did.
- You don't look like
you just became a mom.
Well done.
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah. (chuckles)
- It's been four weeks.
He's like four weeks and a day today.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- Yeah.
- Oh my God, are you tired?
- I'm a little, no, I'm
so happy to be here.
Are you kidding me? Like I'm so-
- [Kelly] You wanted to
say I'm tired. (laughs)
- I'm a little bit tired here and there,
but I find times to nap,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And he's such a good little
baby and I'm so in love.
I mean, you're a mom.
- [Kelly] Awww. Yes.
- It's the greatest, it's my
greatest job I'll ever have.
- One hun- and it will
be, I know it's so cliche
but it will be the hardest, because you,
the hardest thing for me is
when they're so freaking cute
and you love them so much
but they're doing
something that's naughty.
- Right.
- And you're like, "Nope."
- [Katharine] Whoa.
- You will not twist
me around your finger.
- Someone told me that.
My girlfriend who was doing my hair today,
she was like, "Oh, can you even imagine
that you're gonna have to
get mad at him one day?"
I'm like, "No, he's so sweet
right now. I can't imagine."
- Trust me, it'll happen,
it'll happen, and you'll go,
"Whose child are you?"
(both laugh)
- [Katharine] Exactly, yeah.